what's going on guys
Avengers endgame it's in theaters now
smashing records it's the 22nd film for
over the course of 11 years
so we at screen junkies decided to take
on the pretty simple task of ranking
every film in the MCU yeah I'm not
saying it takes heroes to figure this
out but I'm not not saying that we've
polled almost everybody here
they sent the rankings they've been
averaged out so this is our composite
ranking but it's not the final rate is
they they jump out at any one is there
any point of contention that we need to
discuss right now sure strange being
that loes criminals just on the visuals
and the third act yes they broke the
chain of the underwhelming same CGI army
clashing together third act I had the
last one to be fair I also didn't see
the theater I saw it at home so that
could make it different on a good laptop
it's not a good laptop movie I write to
very low I also saw it on a laptop for
the first time let's take it out of the
17 spot let's just put it to the side
throw the dark world does anyone have
any problem with keeping Thor the dark
world at number 21 or do you feel that
another one of these films deserves
something next-to-last fine so why not
agree with that why do you think it
deserves both it's more than I think
Thor the dark world deserves like a the
Thor Loki relationship is really good in
it their play against each other and Men
and the wasp is just a way to explain
what happens in endgame for me there's
like 20 villains
and none of them matter I appreciate
just a Paul Rudd big-budget comedy slash
heist movie with a John when we're at
Marvel stuff around it or not that's
just automatically in the middle of the
pack for me well we'll put him in and
wasp over here and Doctor Strange land
for now a veteran's age of Ultron number
19 my gut is that I didn't love it when
I walked out of the theater I kind of
walked out it was like I feel like I
shouldn't be going to another Avengers
movies it's that soon into the MCU it
felt a little try hard to me in the same
way that Deadpool 2 was trying to be
funny like the glib one-liner is when
they're reinterred in the beginning of
Ultron I'm just like oh forced joke
forced joke
language see I disagree I had language
which i think is one of the better
Captain America of all this and for gosh
sake watch your language
the drinking scene is great but that's
kind of a highway I mean all these
movies have like a fun scene or two but
this this one it really is the one
that's burdened by the weight of so much
overarching story and I think they still
hadn't figured out how to integrate that
with its own original story it's doing
so much world building for the MCU that
really drags it down
I read Captain Marvel very low of the
origin stories that was the one for me
that worked the least I would put Doctor
Strange above Captain Marvel and hitman
in the loss I might I I agree with you I
think you could actually take Thor and
Captain Marvel and just port them down
to 17 and 18 instead of 50 that's me
this column seems to be our trouble area
right now yeah where it's always the mid
section isn't where do all of these
movies go let's all really like that
first door huh I'm a big fan of the
first one I liked it more than First
Avenger I like I like I like Hemsworth
Hemsworth clearly like got the character
right off and have jumps in but that's
all that works about that first orbit I
think Loki works
I think it's works well I like that
scene on Jotunheim the big battle with
the hammer against all the frost giants
in the beginning but I I would put it
above guardians to i Captain America the
First Avenger I would not move that down
any other way yeah I loved it alright so
the First Avenger staying in at 14 we
know that for sure
we have Doctor Strange and guardians 2
over here we have Thor Captain Marvel in
these 2 empty spots here y'all really
love Doctor Strange I would say if it's
a choice between the two I'd put
guardians to at 70 and then ship the one
Captain Marvel down and okay
Doctor Strange I see is it 13 yeah
let's just see what that looks like
yeah how about that so let's just try it
on and see how it looks so Captain
Marvel moves down 1 yes yeah what's at
number 15 guardians to guardians news
better than Captain America the First
Avenger I would flip Captain Marvel and
guardians to but I know that's a losing
battle
I flip guardians to in Captain America
First Avenger I would - what do you guys
have against captains I have nothing
against cam I hate a captain I'll flip
flop Captain Marvel and Thor right now I
will flip flop at Marvel Thor I believe
if I recall this is where Captain Marvel
wasn't so here oh okay there's been some
back-and-forth there's been some
switcheroo so movies were put off to the
side then brought back in putting time
out taken out of time out but we're
about halfway through let's see how it
stacks up so far 22 The Incredible Hulk
21 Thor the dark world 20 Ironborn 18
ant-man and the wasp 17 Thor 16 Captain
Marvel 15 guardians of the galaxy vol 2
14 Captain America the First Avenger 13
Doctor Strange it was already hard
getting that part of the list but now
we've got the top 12 films to figure out
all of our favorites in there how are we
gonna do this whatever it takes
screen junkies assemble well we're
already assembled we're already sitting
in the room so yeah let's just go back
and take a look huh big picture anything
people have a problem with a ranking so
no right now is it number 9 that feels -
that's partly my fault Iraq did pretty
well I just don't I don't like it I just
I don't know like the at the 10th full
action sequences in that movie can stand
up against any
man funky fight isn't he I mean it's it
looks kind of cool but it's two against
one it's not even remotely fair oh
you're talking about a good even matchup
against one iron man cat I've got to
make out with his niece I put it at
number two I'm gonna make another
unpopular plea right off of that
hairline spider-man homecoming - hi Oh
speak your piece about spider-man
homecoming I you know it's Michael
Keaton is great he's a terrific villain
other than that the movies a lot of
stuff we've seen a hundred times already
it doesn't really do anything to blow up
the expectations of a spider-man movie
it's just this great vulture performance
and character the like substitute father
mentor of Tony Stark and and spider-man
really cool well it was like a buddy
movie without and also I thought it did
some fun introduction of like who the
spider suit can now do cool interesting
things like I thought it really
introduced all the new tech really well
you're treading bananas because they
didn't start with the origin story so
you hit the ground running number 12 and
number 11 Iron Man 3 and ant-man
so it goes the number one does anyone
want to advocate for either one of these
two entering the top ten or we just
leave them where they are
people hate our main three for the twist
I love the idea of the twist the only
thing that makes it fail is the fact
that the twist is that it's boring like
a boring blonde dude that is the actual
guy like I like the twist of the
Mandarin being a fake like a fake I
really like but then like the fact that
is just this guy who's like it's Guy
Pearce with dragon tattoos okay Aaron
Man 3 it's just up against really like
guys yeah yeah I just don't I think
there's a little bit too much time of
like I'm stuck in Tennessee I don't have
any of my powers I've got to like figure
myself out like that drags a little bit
other than that I should think Iron Man
3 is a lot of fun is there any lunch at
Neptune's net that's a great seat that
is a great season true story oh gee
Avengers should be much higher on the
list it should definitely be higher than
infinity I tend to disagree I the third
act of the Avengers is fantastic but I
feel like the first act is a little bit
of a log to me the first Avengers movie
feels like it is 100% a comic book
team-up and so many of these other
movies transcend that and and are able
to make it more than its source material
that's why I would advocate moving it
down a little bit of something I like it
I think it handled in an ensemble better
than Infinity Ward did
infinity war had a heavier lift of an
ensemble but I still think Avengers
managed its moving parts better Civil
War
spider-man homecoming what do we want to
do with them I put a homecoming over
Civil War but I also love you guys too
much I don't want to fight
that's a great discussion so Ironman is
being taken for granted
and is now criminally underrated yes in
this list we simply to be in the top
five it's a movie that absolutely
succeeds on its own terms and doesn't
require anything else to appreciate it
this takes non-comic from turns people
have never heard of Tony Stark control
life and makes them fall in love with
the character and getting the comics in
the first place so yeah to be able to do
that with a at the time B or C level of
comic book character yeah Batman wasn't
Superman wasn't even the excellent is I
think Jeff Bridges gets forgotten he's
such a great duplicity villain he's got
that one great Tony Stark okay Tony
Stark was able to build this in a cave
the one that people would probably have
the line is Avengers in game are we
recently goddesses a moment and is it
too high to be in the top five I don't
know I think it's I think five is a
great spot yeah I mean I do think as
time goes on and we that movie stitch
with this longer will say the same thing
like wow great third act but man the
beginning like it's a lot of time travel
that doesn't quite add up and a lot of
just like it's a greatest hits clip show
you know it's not bringing as much new
to the table was clearly not right I
would like with them all in jail
discussing sure let's be fair when we at
the end of our screening we literally
turn to each other and said who doesn't
love a greatest hits album yeah I would
move thor ragnarok to six and I would
put in game at number four that's what I
like cosine that no I don't agree Red
Rocks my favorite marble yeah
yeah I have to take away my bias because
my bias is always gonna be with just
straight-up balls-out comedy so it's a
group pranking you have to take out your
bias just the funniest I think you know
maybe then be fair put that aside but
it's also may be the best-looking one
like the best design yeah yeah yeah
brought that universe to life in a way
that all these movies kind of have the
veneer of like a nice TV show but that
one looks like a movie the end game
heads like it's so much riding on it and
it delivered and and like I'm a jaded
but it like it me it made me well up and
I didn't think I was gonna I was reading
all these reactions I'm like they happen
if it didn't hit me feel sick ummul
ative effect of the MCU experience or
that just that movie I don't know that's
acute ya know I really think the problem
with endgame is not the finale and the
third act in the send-off the way they
tied it all up for me it's a slog to get
there I'm sorry you know a long time
what's crazy cuz you said the first
Avengers an endgame felt like that -
it's the inverse for me like neither of
those feel like a slog to me and
infinity war was the one where I was
like just checking that was a watch Jack
I'm not very good at improv if we're
gonna remove the discussion of in gaming
in the top five could we agree to ranked
it at number six yeah okay it's weird
there's so much jibber-jabber before
this but now it's like there's a method
to the madness the only thing that keeps
Black Panther from 1 or 2 for me is the
the third act yeah yeah CGI train fight
is the only thing that kind of knocks it
down a little for me guardians is why
it's not my number one was the third act
dance-off finale
probably you can find some problem with
everyone yeah I actually like that the
dance-off itself I'm not crazy about but
once they all grab ahold of the power
start is actually a really nice moment
yeah and it fits totally yeah let's take
a vote is this our consensus ranking
democracy is compromised there we go as
they're the definitive rankings that's
it Marvel said right
every other channels is wrong send it to
by E lock it in and more than more than
every other channel specifically at home
yours is also that was intense it was
such a long journey that we almost had
to break for lunch a little bit later
than we had expected but we got there
here are the top 12 films in the MCU
number 12 ant-man number 11 Iron Man 3
number 10 the Avengers number 9
spider-man homecoming number 8 Avengers
infinity war number 7 Captain America
Civil War number 6
Avengers end game number 5 Iron Man
number 4 thor ragnarok number 3 Black
Panther number 2 Captain America the
Winter Soldier and number 1 guardians of
the galaxy
there it is the definitive list
Hetch it into stone and put it in a
museum for posterity
what's your list do you agree with ours
do you hate ours let us know in the
comments section below
we want to know thanks for watching
screen junkies hit me up on Twitter bye
bye